another example that's close to our
hearts our Ted where video is sometimes
more powerful than print the sharing of
an idea why do people like watching TED
Talks
all those ideas already out there in
print it's actually faster to read them
to view why would someone bother well we
see there's some showing as well as
telling but even leaving the screen out
of it there's still a lot more being
transferred than just words and it's in
that non verbal portion there's some
serious magic somewhere hidden in the
physical gestures the vocal cadence the
facial expressions that eye contact
the passion kind of awkward British body
language the you know the sense of how
the audience are reacting that there are
hundreds of subconscious clues that go
to how well you will understand and
whether you are inspired light if you
like and desire and credibly all of this
can be communicated on just a few square
inches of a screen reading and writing
are actually relatively recent
inventions face-to-face communication
has been fine-tuned by millions of years
of evolution that's what's made it into
this mysterious powerful thing it is
someone speaks there's resonance in all
these receding brains the whole group
acts together I mean this is the
connective tissue of the humans super
organism in action it's probably driven
our culture for millennia five hundred
years ago it ran into a competitor with
a lethal advantage it's right here print
scaled the world's ambitious innovators
and influencers now could get their
ideas to spread far and wide and so you
know the art of the spoken word pretty
much withered on the vine
but now in the blink of an eye the game
has changed again it's not too much to
say that what Gutenberg did for writing
online video can now do for face-to-face
communication so that primal medium
which your brain is exquisitely yi4 that
just went global now this is big we we
may have to reinvent an ancient art form
I mean today one person speaking can be
seen by millions shedding bright light
on potent ideas creating intense desire
for learning and to respond and in his
case intense desire to laugh for the
first time in human history talented
students don't have to have their
potential in their dreams written out of
history by lousy teachers they can sit
two feet in front of the world's finest
now Ted is just a small part of this I
mean the world's universities are
opening up their curricula thousands of
individuals and organizations are
showing their knowledge and data online
thousands of people are figuring out new
ways to learn and crucially to respond
completing the cycle and so as we've
thought about this you know it's become
clear to us what the next stage of Ted's
evolution has to be TED Talks can't be a
one-way process one too many our future
is many too many so we're dreaming of
ways to make it easier for you the
global tech community to respond to
speakers to contribute your own ideas
maybe even your own TED Talks and to
help shine a light on the very best of
what's out there because if we can
bubble up the very best from a vastly
larger pool this wheel turns now is it
possible to imagine a similar process to
this happening to global education
overall I mean does it have to be this
painful top-down process why not a self
fueling cycle in which we all can
participate
it's the participation age right schools
can't be silos
can't stop learning age 21 what if in
the coming proud of 9 billion what if
that crowd could learn enough to be net
contributors instead of net plunderers
that changes everything right I mean
that would take more teachers than we've
ever had but the good news is they are
out there they're in the crowd and the
crowd is switching on lights and we can
see them for the first time not was an
undifferentiated mass of strangers but
as individuals we can learn from who's
the teacher you're the teacher you're
part of the crowd that may be about to
launch the biggest learning cycle in
human history a cycle capable of
carrying all of us to a smarter wiser
more beautiful place here's a group of
kids in a village in Pakistan near where
I grew up well in five years each of
these kids is gonna have access to a
cell phone capable a full-on web video
and capable of uploading video to the
web and is it crazy to think that this
girl on the back of the right in 15
years might be sharing the idea that
keeps the world beautiful for your
grandchildren it's not crazy it's
actually happening right now want to
introduce you to a good friend of Ted
who just happens to live in Africa's
biggest shanty town hi my name is
Christopher Macau I'm one of the
organizers of today's Kabira there are
so many good things which are happening
right I am Kira there is a self-help
group they are turn our trash placed
into a garden the same sport it was a
crime sport where people were being
robbed they used the same trash to form
Green Manuel the central site is feeding
more than 30 families we have our own
Film School they are using flip cameras
to record edit and reporting to their
own Channel Kabira
TV the code of scarcity of land we are
using the sack to grow vegetables and
also able to save on the course
of living changes happens when we see
things differently
today I see Camila in a different way my
message to Ted global and the entire
world is kuvira is a hotbed of
innovation and ideas you know what I
thought Chris has always been an
inspiring guy what's new and it's huge
is that for the first time we get to see
him and he can see us right now Chris
and Kevin and Dennis and Dixon and their
friends are watching us in Nairobi right
now guys we've learned from you today
thank you and thank you